today on the matt walsh show many on the
left have been nobly
sermonizing about our civic duty to pay
taxes but they have a very strange and
inconsistent view on civic duties and
obligations we'll talk about that today
also five headlines including
the media's continued attempts to smear
amy coney barrett on the basis that
she's a bible-believing christian
imagine that plus
the push to lower the voting age to 16.
that's a terrible idea for so many
reasons
it's difficult to count them all but
we'll try and in our daily cancellation
we will be canceling grown men who use
emojis i have discovered that this is an
issue of national interest and
importance and uh we will talk about
that today all that on the way but first
let's talk about our latest sponsor
thinker you know it's important to read
i really believe that if you become the
sort of person who just
binge watches tv and scrolls social
social media all day
you'll become dumber and i i know that
when i go through a phase where i'm not
reading much and
just watching a lot of tv i can feel
myself getting dumber by the minute and
i don't have a lot of brain power to
spare in the first place as you know so
this is a crisis situation
but the problem is that sometimes it
could feel like we don't have you know
the time to read and
challenge our minds in that way even
though we probably do have the time
given all the tv we're watching but even
so
whether your time constraints are real
or imagined thinker
solves a problem at thinker.org they
summarize the key ideas from new and
noteworthy nonfiction giving you access
to an entire library of great
uh books but in bite-sized forms you can
read
or listen to hundreds of titles in a
matter of minutes from
old classics um to recent bestsellers
everything in between they even have my
book on there
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across many categories current affairs
politics business education
history relationships i've been using
thinker for a long time and
it's great to get the basic ideas from a
non-fiction book
some food for the brain and also a lot
of times i'll use it to see if a book is
worth investing the time in you know
i'll use it as kind of a preview of a
book
before i buy the full thing there are a
ton of uses for thinker you've got to
check it out
if you want to challenge your
preconceptions expand your horizon
and become a better thinker go to
thinkor.org that's
t-h-i-n-k to start a free trial
and download the app today let them know
you heard about them
on the mat wall show by the way that's
thinker.org
all right well we prepare ourselves
today for the debate
uh tonight between joe biden and donald
trump it is
i would say malpractice on the part of
biden's staff that they're letting him
do this in the first place i was quite
sure that the biden camp would find a
reason to pull out
um it looks like they're they're not
going to um
and it's it's not like they needed a
good reason you know they the media has
their back they could just come up with
any old excuse
to not do the debate but and any excuse
i think would be better than
sending their dementia riddled candidate
into a debate against an opponent who
will not follow
any predictable script so it's just the
worst possible combination if you're
joe biden's team and yet that's what's
going to happen now
we can expect of course that the issue
of trump's taxes will figure
significantly into the discussion
tonight um it was designed that way
that's why the times published it
when it did the media again of course is
a propaganda wing of the democrat party
and is always looking to help their side
any way they can and that's what this
whole tax thing is about
now as we prepare to hear a lot about
the taxes tonight
i have a couple of other points i want
to make on this manufactured
controversy and the reaction to it
especially
i already argued yesterday that that
trump legally avoiding taxes that is
simply making sure that he doesn't pay
more than is legally required to pay
uh is not a scandal not even close to a
scandal it is if anything sort of the
opposite of a scandal for a man to
ensure
that the government gets not one dime
more than it claims to be owed
but i noticed two things in the reaction
to the story first
it's obvious that there are many
americans who don't hate the irs
enough now to the sane and well adjusted
it seems almost impossible to believe
that such a group could exist people not
hating the irs
is like people not hating the idea of
being trampled to death by a rampaging
moose i mean
aren't we all proud members of the anti
getting our brains
brains stomped out by large hooved
animals camp
uh but apparently we don't all value our
brains or our money in the same way
in the discussion about the massive
scandal of trump legally avoiding
paying more taxes than he owes many
people have reacted with shock and
horror
at those of us who are quite in favor of
citizens
paying as little as they can and not a
penny more these people speak
nobly of our civic duty to pay taxes
and they profess that they they have no
resentment about chipping in their share
paying taxes is fun they comparison
close to saying
this is perverse you know there are ads
in the personal section on craigslist
that are less pathetic and weird than
this
i know we aren't supposed to kink shame
but if your kink is paying taxes well
you need to seek counseling yet we know
the real reason
that so many in our country don't
experience the appropriate levels of
rage when it comes to taxes rage that
should be all the more fiery and
righteous
given the fact that the government
absorbs over three trillion dollars a
year
in taxes and wastes an enormous portion
of it
the reason this doesn't induce the rage
that it should is that
many of the people who seem basically
okay with it
actually don't pay income tax at least
they don't actively pay it
the taxes come out of their paycheck
automatically withheld
is the term quite painless and easy and
then come tax time
they actually get some of some of that
money back or all of it back
so for the average american the only
direct experience
they have with the irs is when the irs
is
giving quote unquote them money of
course it's their own money they're
being given back money that was taken
held paid back without interest but even
so psychologically emotionally
it feels like a belated christmas bonus
this is all by design this is why the
withholding system i believe is one of
the most sinister and
dastardly and brilliant schemes ever
devised by the government
because it allows them to take as i said
trillions and trillions of dollars from
the american people squandering
billions every year squandering billions
of our money money that that you could
use
to buy your child a pair of shoes that
he needs or save for a new home or go on
a
much needed vacation or anything else
but that the government takes
instead and and essentially incinerates
but it can do this
without causing an uproar or a
revolution
or even any real heartburn in most
people simply by
helping itself to your paycheck first
and then giving you the leftovers
in fact it can even turn tax time into a
happy occasion
by giving some of the money at pilfered
back to you
this is why if there's any real red pill
moment in american life
it's when you get into a line of work
where not all
or perhaps none of your taxes are
withheld when you actually have to
write physical checks to the government
when you feel the loss
when you see it and then come tax time
if you're
under if you underestimated your taxes
throughout the year you have to pay even
more
this is the awakening this is the
realization okay you begin to
realize just how much the government is
actually taking
and how little you are getting in return
on your investment
and you begin to make calculations and
you say to yourself man if i didn't have
to write this check to the irs right now
i could do this or that i could buy this
i could save for that
it's real now taxes are real and you
start to understand your relationship to
the government you understand
what that relationship actually is it is
one where you
give and give and give and give and give
and give
uh it's and then you give some more it's
very one-sided
and then every pothole you drive over
and every piece of pork
added to a bill becomes a personal
affront to you
because you say what the hell am i
paying for where is the return on my
investment what are you people
doing with my money and that's exactly
how you should feel it's how our
founders felt
and it's why this country exists in the
first place
but it's not how the government wants
you to feel and they have successfully
ensured that many of us don't
second point and this is related to the
first
my daily wire colleague emily zanati
made this observation i wish i had
thought of it first to be honest and
frankly i'm a little offended that i
wasn't given the opportunity to think of
it first but
at any rate um responding to a tweet
from a guy who says
real patriots pay taxes gross which is
exactly the argument that king george
made to the colonists by the way so we
so we know what side this guy is on
but emily says uh i suppose if you
believe this you should also believe
that real patriots
should repay their student loans in full
since that's the money they owe the
the government but i suspect that's
going to be a tough sell
this is a great point because the same
people who speak
solemnly of our obligation to pay our
taxes our civic duty
our responsibility to give what we owe
these very same people almost all of
them would say that the college grads
you know have taken out loans
shouldn't have to repay those loans as
it has done with many other words the
left has twisted the concept of
obligation and distorted it until it's
no longer recognizable
in what sense is paying taxes and
obligation well
it's illegal in a legal sense you have
to pay them because if you don't you'll
go to jail
it's a pretty good reason to pay them
it's why i pay them i have no choice
i'm legally required what about student
loans though well you are legally
required to pay those back too
um so there is a legal obligation but
only in this case it has the extra moral
weights
of being an obligation that you
personally accepted
and entered into chose
nobody chose the obligation of paying
taxes the government just tells you what
the taxes are
uh whether you like it or not and if you
don't pay it they're gonna
take it by force they could throw you in
jail they could take your house whatever
whatever they want but with student
loans
you agree to the terms you don't have to
agree you can say no you can decline to
take on the obligation
yet somehow for the left this obligation
that is willingly entered into
somehow has less moral weight than the
obligation that is thrust upon you
against your will at gunpoint
so this is their idea of civic duty and
then we could add into that by the way
that
they don't consider it much of a an
infringement or
or a denial of your civic duty if you go
loot and riot and burn down stores and
steal stuff that
that also is is is is is uh perfectly in
keeping with your civic duties so
these these concepts and words have been
all twisted to hell and back and that of
course is
is part of the point what they want is
people to be confused
about what their duties are what their
obligations are
and what moral weight all of these
things have that is all
that is always the goal of the left is
to confuse people and we can tell that
they have
very much succeeded let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
you know it's never a good feeling when
that check engine light comes on or
maybe the car starts it starts
you get a little you hear that weird
sound or there's a little bit of a weird
smell you know
you whenever that happens you get that i
know for me
that feeling in the pit of your stomach
and you just think oh my gosh what is
this going to cost me
well that is that is how i used to feel
until i got
car shield now i don't have to worry
about any of that anymore car shield
offers a wide range of protection plans
that can save you thousands for a
covered repair
which means that check engine light
comes on
you get that weird sound whatever it is
it's a lot less scary
when that happens you have the the
freedom to choose your favorite mechanic
or dealership to do the work
and car shield gets the rest taken care
of even if your car breaks down while
you're traveling the choice of a repair
shop is still
up to you on top of that there's no
long-term contracts or commitments
payments are flexible car shield plans
are customizable
to meet your exact needs car shield has
over 1 million drivers
and there's a reason for that because
this is just
it just works for you in the end it's a
it's a it's a positive for you
uh and a lot of peace of mind comes with
it as well that's why they're america's
number one auto protection company
uh and uh that's why that's why i keep
coming back to in the end you save a lot
of money
but also just not having to worry that
the engine light comes on
whatever it is you don't have to have
all that anxiety i used to dread car
repairs with a car shield i have peace
of mind get coverage today and see why
car shield cars go farther
call five seven and 800-665-2157
code walsh or visit car shield dot com
and use code walsh to save ten percent
that's car shield dot com
code walsh a deductible may apply all
right well the media is digging for an
amy coney barrett scandal
and they just they they think they found
one finally uh here's what they came up
with this is from the ap
it says president donald trump's nominee
for the u.s supreme court has close ties
to a charismatic christian religious
group that holds that men are divinely
ordained as the head of the family
former members of the group call people
of praise called people of praise say it
teaches that wives must submit to the
will of their husbands
federal appeals judge kamikota barrett
has not commented publicly about her own
or her family's involvement
uh and so on and so forth but barrett 48
grew up in new orleans and a family
deeply connected to the organization as
recently as
2017 she served as a trustee at the
people of praise-affiliated trinity
schools incorporated
people praises a religious community
based in charismatic catholicism a
movement that grew out of the influence
of pentecostal
pentecostalism which emphasizes a
personal relationship with jesus
barrett's affiliation with a
conservative religious group that
elevates the role of men
has drawn particular scrutiny given that
she would be filling the
high court seat held by justice ruth
bader ginsburg a feminist icon
barrett by contrast is being hailed by
religious conservatives as an
ideological heir to the late justice
scalia okay
well so she belongs to a group that says
that wives should submit to their
husbands
um horrifying horrific stuff
but but just so you know the the actual
name
of this kooky fringe right group is
christians who believe in the bible okay
that that's that's the actual name
because well all christians who believe
in the bible believe this
because it's in the bible uh this is
where you see how the media
obviously they hate christians obviously
but they have difficulty smearing
christians effectively
because they don't know anything about
christianity they're very biblically
illiterate
i bet whoever wrote this ap article for
example didn't know that the bible
specifically says
wives submit to your husbands ephesians
5 22. one of my favorite verses by the
way
um and one that i will often cite to my
wife if we're
say arguing over what movie to watch on
a friday night
then i got to pull out the bible and say
it says it right here
saint paul what can i tell you okay it's
not me it's him
he's telling you but the media doesn't
know that that's why they don't
nowhere in the article is even mentioned
that oh that this is how they interpret
the bible verse or not that there's any
other way to interpret it
uh because they just don't know that by
the way a devout catholic
quote unquote devout catholic joe biden
what about him
he also believes this right if he is if
he really is a devout catholic which he
isn't because he's pro-abortion you
can't be devout catholic and
pro-abortion but
let's just pretend for a moment as the
media wants us to pretend that he's
devout catholic well
in that case then he believes this too
and if we had a real news media
they would ask him about this they would
say hey
uh uh joe what what do you feel about
this
ephesians 5 22 do you think wives should
submit to their husbands
i would love to see the way that he he
wiggles himself out of that but he's not
going to be put in that position because
he's not going to be asked about it
number two
tucker carlson had this report last
night
take a listen more and more lawmakers
are calling for a nationwide rule on
wearing
face coverings senator dianne feinstein
has written to federal agencies asking
for a mandatory mass policy
both in the air and on public transit
well that was news footage from june
just this june when california senator
dianne feinstein wrote a letter to the
faa
demanding everyone wear masks in
airports
feinstein wrote that we need a mandatory
mask policy for
all airport and airline employees and
passengers end quote
feinstein claimed the agency had quote
showed confusion among passengers about
whether masks are necessary but they are
necessary says dianne feinstein
not wearing him is very dangerous given
the coronavirus
well given that today this show
exclusively attained photographs of and
this is going to rock your world
dianne feinstein in a private terminal
at dulles airport
an fbo as they say in private aviation
on friday in the photographs feinstein
can be seen smiling without a mask on
one might even say she's showing
confusion about whether or not masks are
necessary
so there you go you know what annoys me
about these kinds of things aside from
the obvious
is the reaction from the public who
treat some in the public would treat
this sort of thing as a cheap
gotcha tactic you know criticizing
feinstein for not wearing a mask pelosi
for breaking the lockdown
rules mayor lightfoot de blasio etc so
many have done it
but the attitude from some citizens
namely ones with partisan bias in favor
of the party that keeps doing this
the reaction is to go oh come on you
know it's not that big of a deal
but it is a big deal it's a very big
deal
because these people have brought our
country to a standstill
have decimated the con the economy have
torn the constitution to shreds
imposing all these rules and laws on the
basis that they're doing it to save
lives
but their behavior reveals that they
don't really believe
their own reasoning they don't believe
the reasons that they are giving for any
of this
which raises an obvious question
why are they really doing it if they
don't believe it
then why are they doing it
once again going back to the first point
if we had a real news media this would
be a question that would be uh would be
asked
number three daily wire reports
transgender inmates in california will
now be
housed according to their gender
identity thanks to a new law signed
saturday by governor
gavin newsom the law states that prison
officers must privately ask inmates
going through the intake process if they
identify as transgender
non-binary or intersex
okay so every inmate who comes in is
gonna have to be asked now
hey are you are you non-binary
if the inmate indicates one of those
identities
they will be allowed to request a move
to the facility that houses their
preferred gender
oh my gosh this is
there is a caveat to the new law however
if the state has management or security
concerns it will provide a written
explanation of why it denied an inmate
the chance to be housed according to his
or her gender identity
um this exception is not included
because the state believes men will
claim to be women in order to harm
female inmates but because it believes
male inmates will attack biological
women to identify as men
who identify as men okay well i mean
what could possibly go wrong here so
so now according to this it sounds like
um they're going to ask each inmate so
you know
what could go wrong when you go up to an
inmate and say hey by the way um
you go up to a male inmate biologically
male
hey are you um you have are you actually
a woman because if you are you can go
over to the women's prison
just just let us know hey honor system
but that that will never be exploited
right
you see again how this just um
how the the
[Music]
for all of the the talk we hear about on
the left and democrats so they care so
much about women's rights and protecting
women
they don't give a damn they they they
don't give the slightest damn at least
when
when women's rights their actual rights
okay
um are are put up against the lgbt
agenda
you know because there is this hierarchy
this intersectional hierarchy this
victimhood hierarchy that we've talked
about
and women are really pretty low on on
the on the hierarchy scale
lgbt they're above them so their
concerns and their desires come first
so we're going to throw their safety out
the window their privacy out the window
and uh if you know you've got a bunch of
male prisoners that say oh yeah sure
i'm i'm a female yeah in fact i i woke
up yesterday and realized i was a female
as it turns out so yeah
go ahead and send me over to the women's
prison
number four npr reports um
young adults are known for taking to the
streets in protests now there's a
youth-driven push to bring more of them
to the ballot box
tyler okiki a 19-year-old activist is
among those who champion lowering the
voting age from 18 to 16.
okiki is working to increase the number
of eligible voters in in the country's
most diverse generation and amplify
their voices on decisions that will
affect their future
uh and then it goes on from there
talking about his his
efforts to lower the voting age to 16.
there's of course absolutely no good
reason to even consider lowering the
voting age
to 16 or lowering it at all to any age
if anything we should be raising it
the only reason why it's being
considered is that it would help
democrats which is not a good reason
unless you are a democrat
and then i could i could see why you'd
be in favor of it
but in reality objectively our republic
cannot at all be helped by this the last
thing we need
are more people who are ignorant and
non-contributing
filing into the voting booth that's
that's the last thing we do we don't
need more of them
if you're 16 years old and i say this
and anyone
who's over the age of 16 you know this
too because you have
had the experience of being 16.
would you say at 16 that you were really
in touch like
you understood was happening in the
country you had a you had a really solid
perspective
um and you're a real contributing member
of society you were emotionally and
mentally mature would you say that about
yourself at the age of 16
because because if you would then all
that tells me is that you haven't grown
at all from the age of 16
which means that you probably shouldn't
be able to vote now whatever age you are
but anyone who's done any growing any
maturing which maybe is a dwindling
minority
uh we can look back at ourselves at 16
and say no don't give
you give that person the right to vote
are you crazy
no raise the voting age to 25 raise it
to 35
well i'm not 35 yet so don't do that
just raise it raise it raise it to right
where i'm at and then and then
as i as i get older we can keep raising
it along with me
that's the way the law should work
number five important report from the
daily mirror
um a group of parrots at a zoo had to be
put back into isolation when they all
started swearing at customers after
coming out of quarantine
the five african grey parrots were
adopted by lincolnshire wildlife park on
august 15th and put into a room together
but it appears they used their time in
isolation
teaching each other foul language which
left park staff in hysterics but swift
action had to be taken
when they started using obscenities with
guests steve nichols ceo at the frisney
park said the birds were put in a time
out but admitted over the last 25 years
he's taken in many parents
parrots that have sometimes had a bit of
blue language uh he told lincolnshire
live every now and then you'll get one
that swears and it's always funny
we always find it very comical when they
do swear at you but then he continues
that the problem is that now they're
they're
they are um swearing at guests and
there's a concern that especially with
children coming back to the zoo they're
gonna start swearing at the kids be very
traumatizing
to get cussed out by a parrot and so now
they're isolating the parrots and
they're actually gonna break them up
and put the parrots with more
responsible each of the five bad parents
delinquent parents
pet parrots will go with with one of the
responsible parrots
and then hopefully there will be some
you know they'll speaking of maturing
they'll learn to mature that way
a very disturbing report all around and
a pretty serious infringement on free
speech
i don't remember anything in the
constitution saying that you can't swear
a guess at a zoo
i don't seem to recall that in there of
course this is a british zoo
and these are parrots but i don't see
how that has any relevance to the legal
case i'm making here
and besides you can't blame them for
swearing um i'd be a little salty too if
i was locked in a zoo
and if i was a parrot frankly as well
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second it's a
very important one i know i always say
that but this one
this one you can't miss this is this is
a daily cancellation that's more
important than i originally
thought it was we're gonna talk about
that in a second but
this is important as well um new sponsor
on the show
my pillow look uh we all know the value
of a good
good night's rest in fact you you learn
the value of a good good night's rest
when you don't
get one if you if you struggle to get
uh to sleep well at night as i have
struggled in the past
then that's when you really realize what
you're missing um
and that's where my pillow can really
help and ever since i started using my
pill i've been sleeping a lot better
mike lindell is the inventor of my
pillow mike's latest deal
is on his giza dream sheets which are
made from the world's best cotton
giza they're ultra soft they're
breathable very durable
right now the giza dream sheets are at a
two for one low price plus free shipping
with promo code daily wire
all of the my pillow products come with
a 60-day money-back guarantee
uh and uh you know i i could say with mo
with especially with the with the pillow
you know there is a little bit of a
of a struggle a little bit of a fight
with my wife because she's always trying
to steal the pillow
but um what i like about it is that it's
very soft but it's also
it's kind of this combination of soft
and firm it's exactly what you're
looking for in a pillow so it doesn't
doesn't feel like you're laying your
head on a you know bag of
feathers because that's not what you
want either but it's also not like
you're laying on cardboard and i think
most pillows that you get at the store
are kind of they go to one extreme or
the other not my pillow
i've been sleeping a lot better ever
since i started using it so just go to
mypillow.com
click on the radio listener square to
check out the two for one low price on
the giza dream sheets plus free shipping
they're also deep discounts on all
other my pillow products too enter promo
code daily wire or call 800-651-1148 for
these great
radio specials one other point uh before
we
get to the daily cancellation uh tonight
9 p.m eastern 6 pm pacific donald trump
joe joe biden facing off in the first
debate
as we've been talking about today and uh
you could join us for an all-new episode
of daily wire backstage to watch the
debate
with us and get our immediate live
reaction to this major political event
and even better you can join daily wire
now as an insider or all-access member
and get 20
off with cope with code debate so you
can watch all the debate coverage live
on our apple tv or
roku app members get our articles ad
free
you get access to our live broadcast you
get the show libraries you get the full
three hours of ben shapiro show
exclusive readers pass content available
only to the daily wire members you get
that too
if you become an all access member you
get to join our all access live
broadcast every night where we you know
have these live stream discussions that
are a lot of fun very casual
back and forth you also get not one but
two leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products so
you get all of that plus you can watch
the debate with us on dailywire.com
youtube facebook get 20 off your daily
wire membership with code debate
when you sign up today all right let's
get to the daily cancellation
so today our daily cancellation deals
with one of the crucial issues
facing our country and indeed all of
western civilization and that would be
emojis
specifically male induced emojis or mie
as they are called in the medical field
last night i was actually trending i was
trending nationwide on twitter
and you can see the photographic
evidence right here trending nationwide
and also hundreds and hundreds of
infuriated private messages because of
something i said about emojis
now you might say that this is a
reflection of the fact that we live in
the dumbest most frivolous and utterly
decadent culture in world history where
even in the midst of
crisis a guy's tweet about emojis
manages to grab hold of the country's
attention
but i prefer to think that i was
trending because i'm just a really
important and brilliant guy tomato
tomato
you can interpret it however you like
whatever the reason
here was the tweet that brought the
world to a halt
i said every day i see more grown adult
men using emojis there is no excuse for
this emojis are for children and women
do you think your great-grandfather
would have been caught dead using emojis
if the internet existed back then
have some self-respect for god's sake
bless you doubt that i lest you doubt
that i am i am kind and merciful i did
make this allowance i said gifts are
okay though
memes are a case-by-case basis okay now
so those are the rules now
before i elaborate here let's go through
some of the responses to this tweet
about emojis
as i said many many very angry people
let's take a look at a few john pavlovic
says well i hear my great
grandfather wasn't big on insecure dude
bro misogynist
so he'd laugh at matt walsh for his
transparent overcompensation and point
out that his christianity is short one
jesus
and then he called matt a fragile tiny
clown
tom thorne chimes in alexa show me what
the most pathetic toxic masculinity
looks like
gibson john's with a totally normal and
sane response to a tweet about emojis
which has since been deleted but it said
masculinity is a disease
again that was a response to what i said
about emojis james fell
once again very healthy very normal he
says i've never used emojis
as a professional writer i don't like
them but instead prefer to challenge my
vocabulary that being said
this sanctimonious sack of otter snot
what a brainless festering
knuckle eat excrement and expire early
matt
okay telling me to die because of what i
said about emojis nothing overblown
about that
then alan zilberman comments with a
bunch of poop emojis
david lauer is one of many to leave the
middle finger emoji kayla says
children and women ugg some sexism and
toxic masculinity all rolled up into one
set abramson is in on the action he
comments
that this comment is beyond is is stupid
beyond belief as well as misogynistic
goes without saying to anyone who reads
my feed
but as a separate point every comment
i've ever received from a male trumpist
had an emoji in it which makes trumpist
matt walsh
saying this truly mind-blowing yes i'm a
trumpist now sure
okay uh jake wilson with the middle
finger emoji says
you managed to be homophobic and
misogynistic in one joke
so it's homophobic to make fun of emojis
now apparently emojis are an integral
part of
gay culture according to jake wilson
anyway you learn something new every day
and then a lot of this kind of thing in
the private messages as you can see
telling me to eat excrement calling me a
bigot
bigoted against emojis the pro emoji
guys seem to have a real thing about
eating excrement i don't know i guess we
can we can dig into the psychology
behind that some other time
and then mike williams says men are so
fragile on this site
and the crazy thing is he's apparently
talking about me
and not talking about all the grown men
hysterically crying because i made fun
of their little pictures
now i have a few things to say here okay
first i start with and i don't often do
this as you know but i
i start with uh an apology
after reading all of these responses and
really getting a sense for how people
are
feeling uh feeling about it how it
affected them
i'd like to apologize that i said emojis
are for women and children i would i
should have mentioned
that they're also for illiterates so i
apologize for that oversight
second point to the people who are angry
that i lumped women and children
together all i have to say is this
if you're a woman and you want to be
lumped in with children when the ship is
sinking
giving you that vip pass to the front of
the lifeboat line
then you have to put up with being
lumped together in these sorts of
insulting generalizations
that's the price of admission i think
it's a pretty good deal i have to say
i'd take it if the ship was sinking and
someone said okay you can get off with
the children but that means we get to
make fun of you later
fine um third point the real reason
though that i will allow emojis for
children is that
we cannot expect more sophisticated
communication from them you know if
you're at if you're at the age where you
still read books with pictures then
it's okay to type with pictures too i
allow them for women because along with
the fact that they don't have to drown
on the titanic
they also are more aesthetically
inclined they like to make things look
pretty and pleasing to the eye women are
also more exuberant and emotional emojis
are useful to this end
though only within reason i will not
allow them for men because
men don't have any of these excuses as
men we communicate our meaning
plainly and without the frills you
shouldn't need the assistance of smiley
faces
you should be able to convey your
message by using words in the form of
complete sentences
you know i think of emojis much the same
way i think of ketchup
ketchup which is also by the way only
for women and children
if you feel like your ketchup like like
like you need ketchup for your french
fries
that only tells me that your french
fries are not well seasoned
if you feel like you need emojis for
your sentences that only tells me that
your sentences are not well seasoned
that is
you have not done a sufficient job of
expressing yourself through the use of
actual language you have not
you have not the vocabulary to season
your written expressions
with language that creatively conveys
your meaning
i think what we're witnessing in modern
times is the collapse of language
the collapse that's why people say you
know they need the emoji so that others
will
know their tone and their meaning when
they text or email or post something on
social media
they don't have the ability to get their
point across in an effective way
so they need little signs little
drawings that essentially say
me happy me like that's what every
smiley face emoji says by the way
that to translate it into language it
would be me happy
or me sad or me laughing you funny
emojis are quite literally the language
of the caveman
in fact many of the responses to my
point
cited in defensive emojis cave paintings
responses like this with a photo of some
cave paintings which is supposed to
prove that emojis
are an acceptable form of communication
for modern civilized man
but this is like trying to dispel the
idea that pop music is degenerate by
arguing that they played in strip clubs
your argument against my point actually
illustrates my point precisely
yes prehistoric man before the invention
of sophisticated written language did
use a form of emoji
when they were scrawling messages on the
wall of a cave but we should no more
seek to emulate the caveman's
communication style
than his medical practices or his
hygiene routine
we have graduated beyond those crude
forms a return
to them is not a good sign in this case
with writing and language it's a sign
that people are losing their ability to
convey
meaning through the written word that is
not
a positive development
and so emojis are canceled
all men who use them are
everyone who jumped on the twitter dog
pile is canceled
or to express this in a way you'll
understand you bad
you stupid you not right good
you cancelled i hope that clarifies
things
tune in tomorrow because i'll have
another 10 minute explanation as to why
men also are not allowed to use
exclamation points
i could do a whole series on punctuation
as well we'll get to that later
but i think that's quite enough for
today
have a great day everyone godspeed
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
democrats catch trump in a major
non-traversing
project veritas uncovers an illegal
ballot harvesting ring in ilhan omar's
district
and a top democrat senator admits they
can't stop
amy coney barrett check it out on the
michael knowles show